um
I don't really know what I'm gonna say I
usually script like scripture script
write lots of things on the internet but
no I just press record so
um
for those of you who know borders USA
the fifth season of borders was uh in
production and in fact we shot most of
it and developed it and
um yet it was in production at a time
when everything kind of started to
change in this country
these things have changed our country
fundamentally so
borders USA is canceled and will not air
as you can imagine this news is very
difficult for me
um I understand the the reasoning and
yet what this represents for me is a
very abrupt and unforeseen end to
something that I really really loved and
really worked hard to build
I don't know how to describe this other
than borders was more than just a
documentary series for me
um
this project
represented a major transformation in my
life
and became the foundation of so much of
what I do today
back in the early days of Vox when it
was still sort of a startup and there
were just a few of us on the video team
my boss at the time Joe who was the head
of video took a major chance on me he
let me take my camera at that point of
5D Mark III and my tripod and The
Limited budgets we had back then and go
my first time was to Cuba and he just
said make it good and make sure it's
factually accurate that opened something
in me that I didn't really know existed
which was this obsessive voracious
desire to tell stories and explain
things in Far Away places Joe let that
spark catch and over the next several
years that spark turned into a massive
fire and I'm looking for ideas
surrounding a single topic borders
by 2017 we turned it into a series
called Vox borders
we're driving through a river right now
in the Jeep I traveled to six different
border regions around the world in one
summer in the course of 40 days and the
whole time I was pinching myself is this
a dream am I really in a Jeep in Nepal
going up to the Tibet border to tell a
story of nomadic Yak herders am I really
in a North Korean School in Japan eating
kimchi and rice and talking to these
people about their love for their great
leader back in North Korea did I really
just take a nighttime boat ride with a
bunch of merchant women from Haiti to
the Dominican Republic it was a
whirlwind of experiences and a master
class in how to tell stories and
represent people and represent big
issues around the world I am incredibly
grateful for that first season it went
on to get nominated for an Emmy and fox
was like let's do another one and so
then it was Hong Kong five really
compelling stories from cage homes to
feng shui to the story of the British in
Hong Kong and the remnants they left
behind and then Colombia where we looked
into one of the world's most dire border
crises as Venezuela fell apart and
people rushed into Colombia looked into
music and hippos and cocaine
and then finally India the most
intimidating and difficult set of
stories I've ever told hours and hours
pouring over physical maps traversing
from the south of India where we looked
at the Sri Lanka India border all the
way up to the north into Punjab the
Border ceremony the Sikhs looking across
the border at their holy Place learning
about cow Vigilantes and the persecution
of India's Muslims this is hard like I
said this is hard and weird and
nostalgic and my whole body feels it in
some strange way
and yet I at the same time I'm feeling a
deep gratitude
for the fact that I had this opportunity
a gratitude for Christina Thornell who
was the first person I hired when we
started borders to help me build it and
she did and became a Monumental part of
the whole thing helping develop the
stories and get us in places that were
impossible to get into and getting us
the interviews we needed and the story
beats and the visuals and her work is
embedded in every episode and the
stories themselves it's so often that I
was on camera and like you know doing my
thing but there were so many people who
touched these episodes and I just feel
so grateful especially to the editors if
you don't know in journalism an editor
is someone who sort of guides you and
guides your story and helps you pare it
down and helps you focus on the right
things and I'm sure many of you know
Joss Fong the amazingly talented Video
Creator her guidance over the years
made me who I am as a Storyteller every
video you see on this channel has Joss
Fong's fingerprints on them she taught
me how to be a journalist and and I am
forever indebted to her as a Creator and
as an editor and as just a person thank
you Joss you may have noticed that
borders got more rigorous and like
deeper each season and that's because we
got a new story editor Mona who came in
and said like hey what if we made
borders like a hard-hitting like
journalistic series that was like deeper
and more representative of people and
she became my story editor and pushed it
and really taught me what like serious
journalism was and there are so many
people who touched this series from
assistant producers to our engagement
team at Vox who helped push it out to
the world I would love to talk about
every person who touched borders and I
and I did in a slack message to my team
as I was leaving and shutting down
everything at Fox's one of the things
things that became really special for me
was the music in borders
[Music]
starting in Hong Kong I started teaming
up with a music composer Tom Fox who
started building custom music for every
episode of borders guy's amazing and
luckily I still get to work with him he
still makes music for this Channel and
for my other work and he's just one of
the most brilliant musicians I've ever
had the pleasure of working with
[Music]
and I will probably work with him for
decades to come so check out Tom Fox's
music for sure Link in the description
while I am very sad that these stories
that we worked very hard on will sit on
a hard drive somewhere for the rest of
time I am very grateful for the
opportunity I had to work at this place
and the people I got to work with sad
nostalgic part over what's next for me
foreign
I'm gonna keep making YouTube videos I'm
now officially like a full-on YouTuber
this will start to really take a lot
more priority in my life right now the
channel is not big enough that I can go
out into the field and do documentary
stuff but the way it's growing it may be
big enough that I could actually
financially support that so if you're
not subscribed click subscribe it helps
me uh grow so I can do more ambitious
stuff go to patreon.com Johnny Harris
and you can support and get a bunch of
cool stuff if you do it too all of that
will help me make more ambitious videos
and be able to eventually do more sort
of journalistic style stuff right now it
just doesn't make sense financially
number two I'm Gonna Keep focusing on
the startup that I've been building for
the past year which is called bright
trip where we've built a platform where
we publish travel courses how to go on a
trip and have it be way more informed
it's all with beautiful video and
animation and teaching and all of this
stuff so that's the other thing I'm
going to continue to work on number
three I'm still going to be in the
journalism world I reached out to the
New York Times who I've talked to for
many years and said like hey do you guys
want to collaborate on something so I've
been working with the New York Times
which is a really fun and amazing
opportunity and we'll be publishing a
video with them sometime in the near
future so I'll still be doing journalism
in the end the thing I care about most
is again what I talked about what I
learned at Vox which is this love I have
for sharing stories about how the world
works and specifically about how things
work in Far Away places that we're not
maybe familiar with I find great meaning
in that and what all of these things
have in common the YouTube channel
brighttrip the journalism stuff is that
I want to share stories and information
in beautiful ways with you and that's
why I do this that is what my work is
like I said that's something I learned
at Vox because they took a bet on me and
I'm so grateful for that and it's
something I'm going to continue to do on
all of these different platforms so
thank you all for being here and for
those who have been on the borders
journey and along with me thank you for
all of the support throughout these
years it's been good and it's not over
this is just a little fork in the road
I'm not going anywhere I'm gonna keep
telling stories one way or another and I
hope you all can continue on the journey
with me
see you later
foreign
[Music]